ودخلت الى القاعه ادخلوني قالوا لي بعد
خمس دقائق سيدخل الرئيس بالفعل كانت فارغه
دخل بعض الضباط الامريكان اخذوا اماكنهم
واخبرون ان هذه الحاله مؤقته بالنسبه
لدخول الامريكان لكن اصروا على وجود احد
الضباط وكان يرتدي مارينز وقالوا لي هذا
جندي
وانا واثق يعني رجل مخابرات نعم
صار يعني نقاش بيني وبينهم انه هذا الرجل
يعني لا داعي لوجود اثناء اللقاء اللقاء
يقتضيه بين وكيل وموكله يقتضي ان يحاط
بالسريه تامه وهذا حق من حقوقه اصروا على
وجوده اخر اشي يعني قالوا هذا حتى يقدم
لكم الخدمه او يحميكم من بعض يعني عذر
يعني غير مقنع بقى هو وبعد خمس دقائق فعلا
دخل الرئيس
اول ما دخل من الباب اني ما مقابل الرئيس
سابقا اول ما دخل يعني كان
يعني غير منتصب القامه كان يعني عنده نوع
من الحناء من الظرف الشديد يعني الظرف
القاسي اللي عمله بالامريكان او عوم البيت
طيله سنه كامله من الاخفاء
دخل كان شعره طويل
ذقنا ايضا طويل وكان يحمل معطف على اذا
اليسرى ويحمل الحقيبه حقيبه
اليمنى فوضع
المعطف على احد الكراسي
وطبعا طلعت انا حياتها ويعني
بطريقه حميميه
[موسيقى]
فاول ما جلس قبل ما يجلس قال ان لم تكن
راسا فلا تكن اخره فليس الاخر سوى ذنبوه
فالبناء سالتك قلت يعني هذا يعني بيت
الشعر مبني على حدث في الانعم جلسنا بعدين
اثناء الجلوسي بديت اعرفه هو الحدث يعني
حدث فوضوه الامريكان فوضوا انه يعني خلص
ان انتهت من السلطه ممكن يترشح غيرك بس
وفق الشروط الامريكيه
فانه ما يكون هو رئيس ولا يكون اي شيء
بالسلطه مقابل اطلاق صراحه مقابل اطلاق
صراحه ومقابل ايقاف القتال في الفلوجه
يرشح احد
جانبه يصل الى مرتبه رئيس النائب رئيس
دوله بنظام رئاسي
ويطلب ايقاف القتال في الفلوجه يعني
ومقابل اطلاق صراحه يبقى في العراق
يغادر يخرج خارج العراق وكان يرفض كل
لذلك قال لك هذا
البيتا فلا تكون اخره فليس الاخر
والمفهوم واضح
كيف اكمل الحوار معك بعد ان عرفت بنفسي
يعني وضحت لانه انا من المنطقه الفلانيه
وادر ارتباطات ايضا عشائريه في محافظه
محافظه صلاح الدين وعرفت ان احد ابناء
عمومه والدي هو شيخ جزء من عشيرتنا اللي
موجود صلاح الدين كان صديقه وعرفته ايضا
على الشيخ العشيره ايضا صديقه وايضا هو ذو
منصب في الدوله العراقيه فابدا ارتياحها
يعني
التعبير كان واضح يعني على ملامحه وراحه
النفسيه
وسطرت الحديث الان اطمان وبعدين عاد هو
تركه الحديث
قديش كانت مده هذا اللقاء الاول مع الرئيس
العراقي الراحل صدام حسين الجانب الامريكي
حدد المده اربع ساعات ونصف
بعد ان انتهت الاربع ساعات ونصف قال اني
الرئيس قال اني ما شبعت يعني من اخبار
بلدي ما شبعت من اخبار شعبيه فهل يمكن
للجانب الامريكان ان يمدد فنادين على
الضابط الامريكي
وطلبنا من عنده تمديد مدد لنا ساعه
ونص خمسه ساعات